birth rates are not declining evenly
so one example is North and South Korea
so North Korea have just below
replacement level
birth rates which means that their
population is likely to dwindle a little
bit but not very much in the next half
century whereas South Korea boasts the
lowest birth rates in the world not 0.78
I think it is now whereas you need 2.1
to for a placement which means that at
the moment
South Korea has twice as many people as
North Korea but in by 2 2100 is that how
you say it 2100 whatever yeah
that will have reversed so North Korea
will have twice as many people as South
Korea and they're a very very obvious
geopolitical consequences to that in
that it's predicted that in maybe 10 20
years South Korea will no longer be able
to repel a land Invasion from North
Korea because they won't have a big
enough military